speaking of UFOs like didn't Am I Wrong
is was it you whose dad saw UFO yeah and
then they they actually Pro so when I
went on when I went on Rogan that's the
first thing what hold on we just talked
about signs I know we I know just I just
um it's just ridiculous but what you're
an alien guy I thought yeah you're So
Pro alien no I just let just let me just
you serious no you serious you serious
serious yeah you go yo you serious right
you serious so let's let's rewind back a
little bit say that again so let let me
get this straight what I heard yeah what
I heard was your father Yes
saw an alien no
okay all right move on okay here's what
here's what happened here's what
happened so when I went so it's so silly
Bob you said UFO right yes UFO so when I
got on when I went on Rogan the first
thing he said when we opened the show he
said tell me about the the the um UFO so
1973 my mother is pregnant with my older
brother my grandmother aunt and mother
start calling my father outside Tommy
you got to come out and see this now
this is over the Bronx and Yonkers
1973 and there is literally within
throwing distance there is a disc in the
sky bluish kind of hue silent they don't
make noise whatever and my dad's looking
at this [__] thing and everybody's
looking at this thing going holy [__]
now my father mind you is whatever you
picture an Italian from the Bronx just
[__] old school you know that's my
father times 10 okay okay my father
comes in here you would be like what
it's like a show you would be like he's
in character for a movie like he's
coming in he's a stereotypical no he if
he walked in here right now you'd be
like he just came off set wow that's
what it looked yeah like that's it okay
you know Italian over the top
over the top forget about it oh yeah
bada boom bada bing still can't believe
Obama was
President that Italian that I didn't
know that you could have that high Itali
oh [__] yeah he go you believe that
eight years of
that okay that that that's that's that's
how that's how Italian so my dad my dad
could never if my said in my Netflix
special if my dad was a comic he'd be
cancelled halfway through his first joke
they would just take the mic out halfway
through the first bit over just drag him
outside arrest yeah yeah he would be
canceled he'd be on the so he always
thought that people that saw UFOs were
nuts and he would be like they want
attention they're in the midwest they're
Hillbillies they're nuts right so so he
always told me and my brother and my
mother who's religious she said yes and
then after The Story Goes he saw it and
he's thinking to himself I can actually
like that's close I could hit that with
something then he freaked out because he
thought it could be like reading his
mind so he goes inside and he comes back
out and then they look they're all
looking at it and within one second it
turned into a star in the sky right it
turned into a dot yeah and they were
blown away my father says to this day he
wishes he never saw it because he knows
when he saw that everybody there but
then when roog when I was on Rogan you
know the way Rogan has jimie the
producer pull [__] up yeah they pulled
it up and I got a ton of messages
because that night hundreds and hundreds
of thousands of people over the Bronx
and Yonkers saw it and then Rogan thing
pulled up and said that yes it was there
and it and it turned into a dot in the
sky and and it [__] Goosebumps and it
freaked it freaked but here's the
funniest part my father before my
parents got divorced cuz they had a
brutal divorce when when me and my
brother were young but before that my
father was kind of a big wig at AIG in
the city insurance and they had a big
party at the head boss's mansion in Long
Island and this is 1973 mind you okay so
my mother's socializing drinking having
a good time and she goes Tommy get over
here tell everybody about the time you
saw the Flying
Saucer and my dad goes no what the [__]
are you [__] nuts I'm going to get
fired cuz they're going to think I'm a
cook wow but that that's my father has
never changed the story then Giannis was
so interested and Yannis went up to my
mom well my mom's Greek so jannis
[__] loves her yeah uh and he's and
my mom's very religious and you know
that kind of goes against and she told
jannis she's like yeah no it we that's
exactly what we saw but so many people
that night saw it but now people are
seeing UFOs like the Jet Blue flights
now now everybody sees yeah yeah yeah
yeah you I've never seen
one yeah um have you seen one yeah like
when I don't know if it was like a UFO
but it's something that we couldn't
identify at that time but like when we
were younger we were we went my family
and I went to a cemetery to you know for
um pay respects um to who my grandpa a
lot of them are family buried that's
what cemeteries are for well I just I
don't want to be lying who went to pay
respects to